I don't think of myself as a boss I mean
I I think of myself as someone who's
giving direction I think it's healthy
for everyone to lose a job as well as to
gain a job I like people who represent
the best of what they do and if that
turns you into perfectionist then maybe
I am I think the more you go out the
more you see the more you experience
life the more you bring back to your day
job she's a British journalist and
editor
she's been editor-in-chief of Vogue
since 1988 she's Anna Wintour and here
is my take on her top ten rules for
success rule number five is my personal
favorite and I'm curious to figure out
which one you guys like the best I try
and be decisive I try and even if I
don't know what the hell I'm doing I try
to be decisive because I think it's very
comforting and reassuring and important
to the people that work with you to feel
that whoever is in charge knows what
they're doing and knows what they're
thinking and that if it's a yes it's a
yes and it's a no it's a no I mean I
don't think of myself as a boss I mean I
I think of myself as someone who's
giving direction and guidance so and
vice versa and I also know career wise
how important it is not to be too highly
specialized especially these days in the
world of media it is crucial to have
multiple interests and skill sets to
have tried and possibly failed and many
different undertakings the young people
that we hired today at Conde Nast are
fearless polymaths hardworking and
passionate creative and curious
eventually joined Harper's Bazaar us and
in 1976 it was you were fired and I find
that extraordinary no no they were very
clear and that they thought that I would
never understand the American market I
remember I was the editor on one shoot
that was I think it was a French fashion
shows and
I decided that it would be interesting
to have dreadlocks on the models and I
think that that pushed them further than
they could they could bear so that was
that was that was it for me but I you
know I think it's always part of life to
have some knocks as well as some
successes and take risks and you know do
to learn so I think it's healthy for
everyone to lose a job as well as to
gain a job what bored you mediocrity if
you see a collection that is you feel
the designer has been lazy or taking
inspiration from other designers it
doesn't so much as for me as as anger me
what is your best piece of advice for
the next generations influencers I think
it's really to be true to yourself
and listen as much as one is able to
other people whose opinions you respect
and look up to but in the end it has to
come from from you and you you can't
really worry too much by looking to the
left or the right about what the
competition might be doing or other
people in your field might be doing it
has to be a true vision the blur about
your unauthorized biography reads she's
ambitious driven needy a perfectionist
and inside look at the competitive [ __ ]
a [ __ ] world of fashion accurate uh
well I'm very driven by what I do I am
certainly very competitive what else am
i needy I'm probably very needy yes a
[ __ ] reflexions perfectionist oh that's
right [ __ ] versus me well I I hope I'm
not I try not to be but I like people
who represent the best of what they do
and if that turns you into perfectionist
then maybe I am I don't make notes
I don't react very instinctively to ever
being I'm a great believer in traveling
a great deal I don't believe meeting
more than two people in the meeting is
too many really it's true do you know
about stand-ups okay so in Silicon
Valley now when you have a meeting
everybody stands in a circle like
they're meditating that's that's how
maybe I should try that um I I think the
more you go out the more you see the
more you experience life the more you
bring back to your day job so as I was
trying to say in my remarks I think the
problem that big corporations is you get
a lot of people my age trying to hold on
to their jobs and you know clinging on
to their pensions and their retirement
and they're not experiencing you things
and they don't like change and they
don't like disruption so they're either
they don't make a decision or they say
no and as a result they stagnate
so it's terribly important to bring
people in from the outside and not to
remain too insular and also to hire as
many young bright people like all of you
as you can just to teach you how to
think about things completely
differently well I think all of us at
Vogue are always looking for talent
and we're also looking for someone who
has a head on their shoulders and
understand that being talented is
obviously important but they also have
have to have a sense of business and
that being creative and commercial does
two words that can work together it's
very
important to me that I look good when I
go out publicly I like looking at my
clothes rack in the morning and deciding
what to pick out
I enjoy fashion Mollie I mean I I
wouldn't be in this job if I didn't I
think Clara tea is the most import one
of the most important leadership
qualities that one can have I think it's
really important to be very specific and
very clear and what you expect and then
to delegate people respond much better
when they're in a more independent
environment and you're not completely
breathing down their neck all the time
the other thing I think is incredibly
important is to hire divas like Andre
Leon Talley who will disagree with you
and contradict you and not yes you all
the time and not to be scared I have
people of having people working with you
that have different opinions thank you
so much for watching I made this video
because Mari Sylvester asked me to so if
there's a famous entrepreneur that you
want me to profile next leave in the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do
I'd also love to know which of Emma's
top 10 rules had the biggest impact on
you and why leave in the comments and I
will join in the discussion finally want
to give a shout out to Jessie Willowby
Jessie thank you so much for buying a
cop in my book it really means a lot to
me for your chance at a shout out in a
future video make sure to pick up a copy
of the book and email in your receipt so
we can keep track thank you guys so much
for watching continue to believe or
whatever your one word is and I'll see
you soon